es el intento más ambicioso del gobierno
canadiense para restringir el acceso a
las armas de fuego
lo que esto significa es que ya no será
posible comprar vender transferir o
importar armas de fuego en cualquier
lugar de canadá a cannes anywhere en
canadá en otras palabras estamos
limitando el mercado de las armas cortas
marketing
la legislación no prohibiría la posesión
de armas de fuego pero haría ilegal la
compra de las mismas también prohibiría
algunos juguetes que parecen armas el
primer ministro canadiense josh instruyó
dijo que era importante aprobar las
medidas más pronto que tarde' we need
las necesitamos menos violencia con
armas no podemos dejar que el debate
sobre las armas se polariza tanto que no
se haga nada no podemos dejar que eso
ocurra en nuestro país
un guiño al vecino del sur de canadá
donde justo la semana pasada un joven de
18 años armado mató a tiros a 19 niños y
dos profesores en una escuela del estado
de texas según los centros de control de
enfermedades más de 19.000 personas
murieron en homicidios con armas de
fuego en eeuu en 2020 en comparación con
poco menos de 300 en canadá que tiene
una legislación de armas mucho más
fuerte esto se debe en parte a un
tiroteo masivo hace dos años en nueva
escocia que dejó 23 personas muertas
obligados a tomar acción los
legisladores prohibieron la venta y el
uso de más de 1500 rifles de asalto pero
las autoridades canarias dicen que el
verdadero problema puede estar en otra
parte dicen que muchas de las armas
utilizadas para cometer delitos se
importan ilegalmente de eeuu